hey youtubers it's Charlie so thank you
everybody there's submitted questions on
my Captain America trailer video I think
we're all so freaking out a little bit
but this is a very Netflix and chill
type of week just because not a whole
lot of other stuff is happening
seriously if you haven't started
watching Jessica Jones now is the time
to do that well let's get to questions
though here we go reuben brown asks is
it true that peter parker was cut out of
the movie why would they do that you
know a bunch of exclamation points
well he's not confirmed to be out of the
movie he's not confirmed to be in the
movie but Kevin Feige has laughed a lot
of interviews where he said people just
kind of take for granted that he's in
there when you think about the movies
Marvel has coming next year they have
Captain America's Civil War in the
spring and then they have Doctor Strange
happening at the end of the year Tom
Hollands spider-man is supposed to be
introduced in a Marvel film in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe then the year
after that he'll go into his own first
solo film the first film in a new
trilogy at Sony with Marvel's help so if
you're doing a big comic book arc like
say Civil War wouldn't it make the most
sense to use spider-man who is a big
part of that arc in comic book Civil War
but the thought is you know because of
the arrangement that they worked out
with Sony and the way spider-man works
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe he's
not gonna be as big a character as
Captain America or Iron Man he's gonna
be important part of this story just not
a very huge presence in the film when
you think of the scope of spider-man's
role in comic books Civil War like he's
a huge part of it think of that is going
to Black Panther in movies Civil War
Marvel owns 100 percent of the movie
rights to Black Panther so of course
they're gonna focus on him more he's
gonna get his own solo film eventually
too so they're gonna spend more time
with Black Panther than they will with
spider-man
most of the conversation about
spider-man isn't so much about whether
or not he's gonna be in civil war it's
gonna be what his costume is gonna look
like and it's supposed to start out
super loaf I like the kind of costume a
normal 15 year old child would create so
I definitely think he's in there but
it's kind of a Luke Skywalker thing
where they don't put him in any of the
trailers like you don't see it to the
actual film next question Michael asks
who do you think will end up winning
this war Charlie so I assume you're
talking about Captain America or Iron
Man if you've read comic books Civil War
I do think it will go down in a very
similar way because that's kind of
spoilery I'm not gonna say how that ends
if you don't have a Marvel unlimited
account I think that they have a lot of
Civil War and the stuff that comes after
on Marvel unlimited but you'll just have
to double check I've been buying most of
my comics through comics
lately I haven't been using Marvel
unlimited that much recently but I
definitely think that they're gonna go
for the big twist at the end of comic
book Civil War I think they'd be wasting
a big opportunity if they didn't try
even though most of the world knows what
happens during comic books Civil War
that's gonna be really funny awkward
situation that the Star Wars films are
not in Episode seven has the advantage
of being a completely new story that's
not based on anything else
next question dyt asks I know this
sounds strange but my favorite scene was
when Captain America is confronted by
Iron Man and caps Eze it's been a long
day you can feel the tension in that
scene and as much as I love the action
and seeing my favorite heroes the solid
acting performances in those tense
scenes is amazing so yeah that's that's
really where Robert Downey jr. and those
other actors shine is when they're doing
the drama stuff usually when they're
pitching these stories to the actors
they're like okay what's my character
gonna be doing in this what's his arc
they talk about these types of scenes
the big twist or just kind of signposts
that they used to demarcate acts of the
film like well on this act this is gonna
be the big twist but then when they fill
it in with all those character moments
that's when it becomes an actual movie
like a lot of these big films or
rollercoasters
there's the roller-coaster part where
it's just like the thrill of like oh my
god this is happening everything's
exploding on-screen is going crazy and
then there's the really human moments
that you relate to like where you
connect with the characters like cap and
Bucky their friendship next question and
Patrick asks where was the vision I
don't want to see spider-man until the
movie hopefully they learn from Avengers
age of Ultron and aren't releasing as
many clips well I think you're going to
be disappointed if you don't think
they're gonna be releasing a ton of
clips there's gonna be all kinds of this
movie but the vision is probably just
not a huge part of the film so they're
probably using this first trailer to
focus on the biggest stuff even though
half of the Avengers are gonna be in the
movie this is still a Captain America
movie so most of the film like most of
the scenes will follow his perspective
like him walking around interacting with
all the different characters vision is
just a really interesting presence
because he's so powerful he still has
the mind gem which we all know that us
is gonna have to take from him at some
point to form the Infinity Gauntlet so
he's probably not long for this world
but the cool thing is is if you have
read a lot of Scarlet Witch Vision
stories you know they're their big
relationship they've had in the comics
for a long time she is supposed to be
team cap he's supposed to be team Iron
Man so we will get to see some fun
Easter eggs for their comic book
rivalries nobody can fight like lovers
fight and you can you can write as many
fake
as you want about this film there's
gonna be so much Vic on tumblr it's
gonna be ridiculous so just beware of
the tumblr tags that you're searching
you might you might find something that
you didn't want to see next question
Ganga asks whose team are you on
that's actually a good question I think
I'd probably be team captain dove the
underdog he's the man that fights
against the system there's nothing wrong
with choosing teamironman if they did
their job writing the film then there
will be no clear side to take like
everyone will have a good perspective
Ironman just wants to make the world a
safer place Captain America is all about
civil liberties so you should be
conflicted but but I think everybody's
gonna have their favourite going into
this I'll be interested to see if people
enter the film wanting to be on one team
and leave the film wishing that they
were on the other team but you come in
Captain America but you end up
sympathizing with Ironman more at the
end of the film next question chatzi
asks the Avengers call power people
enhanced like agents of shield did
before learning about Inhumans pretty
sure that the term Inhumans is still
only used within shield and they're
trying to keep them secret from the
world yeah I think you had the right
idea I think they're gonna use that term
enhanced or gifted during Captain
America Civil War although I do think
the Inhumans movie is still supposed to
be happening that they're still trying
to make it happen
so I think at a certain point they will
become a public thing and the Avengers
will start using that term that'll
probably happen sometime around infinity
ward's they head into phase four
I think phase four you'll see a lot more
Inhumans stuff happening in the movie
universe I know there's a lot of rumors
about the Inhumans movie being tanked
when Kevin Feige and Marvel Studios kind
of broke off into their own group but as
far as I know it's still on the boards
like it's still gonna happen eventually
it's the interesting thing that Vin
Diesel has said about the Inhumans movie
in plaque bolt specifically is that it's
not so much about him courting Marvel is
about Marvel courting him with the right
script like he made it sound like Marvel
is totally down with him being Black
Bolt it just they they haven't found the
right script yet next question al k asks
when does the Punisher series come out
is it before after daredevil season 2
well I mean it'll definitely have to be
after because Punisher is only showing
up for the first time in daredevil
season 2 but the rumor is is that they
like him so much they like Jon Bernthal
performance so much that they're gonna
try and stick him in a whole bunch of
other stuff there are a couple options
they could give him his own series which
i think is the most likely thing or they
could just put him in a bunch of other
series and I think for the most part
they're gonna keep him local to the
Netflix series so like Luke Cage iron
fist
daredevil although series the Netflix
characters are supposed to appear in
infinity war in some kind of way like
after they become the defenders they're
supposed to show up an infinity war so
that'd be the logical place to SiC
Punisher in the movies like he's not
gonna show up and thor ragnarok punisher
in the movies when the other netflix
characters go to the movies
what i want Jon Bernthal to do though is
dress up in his punisher costume and
crash the Captain America Civil War
press tour and have Chris Evans just say
no dude you are way too crazy we don't
want your help please go home that's
kind of what happens during comic-book
Civil War with team cap they're like
okay thanks for helping us out Punisher
but you are way too crazy for us why
don't just just go home just go do your
own thing
next question Mary Beth asks is more and
more movies are made it seems like they
stand less and less on their own for
someone that hasn't read the comic books
and watched only a few prior movies in
the Marvel series what's the best order
to watch the movies to better understand
everything leading up to this movie I
assume you're talking about Captain
America Civil War do you need to watch
any of the TV shows as well well if you
really wanted to you could skip all the
TV shows like you don't need to watch
those and I would just watch the movies
in chronological order just to keep it
simple if you go to Marvel's movie wiki
page it has a list for all their movies
in the chronological order in which they
appeared just watch them in that order
it's real simple where you start
watching the movies just depends on how
familiar you feel like you are with the
characters like if you already know who
the Avengers are like you know who Thor
is you know Captain America's you could
probably just start with the phase 2
movies but if you are a glutton for
punishment you could totally marathon
every single Marvel movie in
chronological order and watch all the
seasons of all the TV shows at least the
live-action shows the cartoon storylines
don't have anything to do with the
movies thank you so much everyone for so
many questions these are always a ton of
fun to do this is a pretty down week so
I'm gonna try and do q and A's for a
bunch of other stuff like Game of
Thrones maybe some Star Wars q and A's
too but congratulations to the giveaway
winner Jarvis Bailey awesome name you
and the movie gift certificates just be
sure to private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact info if any of you guys just
found me in the last week or so like
you're new to my channel are usually too
giveaways every week for Marvel DC Star
Wars stuff Game of Thrones all kinds
awesome stuff so if you're not sure
about how any of that stuff works just
watch a couple of my videos from other
fandoms it's real simple I try to keep
it as simple as possible what's going to
happen next is there's a bunch of
like a Jones that I have to finish
there's a game of Thrones Q&A that I
want to do there's a little bit more
Star Wars there's some more flash and
arrow stuff and some DC movies stuff too
they release some more information about
Doctor Strange as well mass Mikkelsen
was confirmed for Doctor Strange so I am
super pumped about that probably playing
Dormammu but we can talk about that when
I post my next Doctor Strange video be
sure to subscribe to get everything and
I totally take requests so there are
videos that you don't see me doing that
you guys really want me to do feel free
to let me know in the comments just in
case you guys want to watch it like 15
billion more times you can click here
for the Captain America civil war
trailer and you can click here for all
my Jessica Jones videos this is the week
to catch up on Jessica Jones thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you